this is a production of Cornell
University
Mike this is what we woke up to this
morning today brother it did look like
spring dr. Rossi and just remind
everybody we're happy to be with you
this is our fourth week together just
really looking at these things and
trying to support each other the variety
of challenges the confusion the flying
without a net variability among school
districts and operations and facilities
and you know the the what lies ahead for
organized sports where there's regular
contact you know there's so many
challenges that just a reminder that
there's a peaceful place here in central
New York except that's covered in
several inches of snow and though and
don't think I didn't give the weatherman
who I know personally a hard time about
this this morning so so again as we said
about as we said about to you know do
our days and and face those challenges
and and distract ourselves for half an
hour talking about grass one of the
things that's really important is you
know there's a lot more that unites us
that separates us even though we see a
lot of discord in our society today
again hoping to distract you from that
and get you around the purposeful things
the purposeful work that we do every day
that really matters as much okay if you
if you you don't want to listen to me or
watch and listen to this on a weekly
basis certainly you can read about the
things that we talked about now we've
gone to this format to provide
additional support but our 21st year of
our weekly newsletter during the growing
season we publish about 25 to 30 of
these issues a year very much pertinent
to the kinds of things we're facing if
you'd like a copy feel free to sign up
well I couldn't be happier to see STM a
and Kim heck and the leadership meeting
as a board and continue to lead this
group of professionals you know as we
move into the you know raising the
professional stature of you as a sports
turf manager the variety of ways that
you can do it and really now is an
opportune time to demonstrate that
professionalism in this industry and the
STM a
has done a great job in putting together
some resources and and I'll just remind
you if you go to this page you'll find
these webinars listed nationally as an
important resource so big shout to the
STM a guys for folks for really
promoting education and the
professionalism there and this is a good
place to keep checking back there
collected resources there's a great
article in there by Adam Tom's and Nick
Christians another one by Grady Miller
for folks two more to the South that
have had a lockdown dropped on them
roughly and they can't get to their
fields ok so what do you do if I can't
get on my fields right now so obviously
really worthwhile to include these
websites on these sites as part of your
Learning Network you know what are the
things you use to then communicate to
the people that you're servicing another
big shout out to - Pam Surratt and and
the folks at Ohio State University for
this wonderful thing we talked about
last week and also the importance of
safety right and it starts with making
sure you know if the sports that are
allowed on these fields are not
happening and and doing them puts people
at risk and those activities are not
permitted you know you ought to put
signs up and do your due diligence and
making sure at least you know you're
putting your signs up and restricting
access as much as humanly possible to do
and these are sort of the nuts and bolts
that have nothing to do with grown grass
right these things have nothing to do
with growing grass and yet they can
determine the success of our operation
particularly during these enormous ly
difficult times so I'm checking back
with the school facility managers
Institute this the New York state school
district building and grounds and
facility managers and saw again that now
we went up to about a hundred and one
responses so if you look at the graph
oops sorry you look at the graph there
sorry we'll do it one more time so that
was last week they had about 80 answers
they basically said the current we
currently have limited staff I'm doing
building checks and limited repair
operations
the second one limited staff preventive
maintenance so they're doing pretty good
full or near full you can see that
there's a very few places have full
staff if you look at the majority that
was last week and just look at the bar
graph you see a little bit of shift
there's a little bit of shift right in
here let's do that again
right oh no yes no no no it's not gonna
work okay
no it's not gonna work so I lost the
ability there we go so anyway most
people have limited staff and that's
part of our conversation for today so
let's review some weather stuff this is
when we met just a couple of weeks ago
well three weeks ago on March 30th when
we talked about soil temperature you can
see down where Mike is in Virginia back
then he was well advanced of us well
into the growing season but you can see
back then we were still mostly in the
30s and 40s with very little area into
the 50s so you get the DC last week you
could see a big push and of course this
is going to be very much tied to
temperature which when we woke up in
central New York was pretty cool the
other day and so you see the 50s still
barely making it into the south and
central New Jersey on a regular basis
and again Mike probably much more
advanced this is good environmental data
to use covering the way you're advancing
right the govern the way the kinds of
strategic ways you're going to manage
your turf so again growing degree days
bass 50 accumulated since March first we
forecast them every week so back on the
31st of March to the 6th of April we
forecasted almost just single digits for
much of us up here not much advancement
of the growing season it advanced a
little bit more last year especially
last week especially to the south but
still not not you know just low
double-digit accumulations and the
forecast for this coming week continues
to indicate that the growing season in
the Northeast is in a stall and so you
know you're going to get a reprieve from
the regular mowing activity
now again another measure to use is well
how much can my grass grow now it's
interesting you know for us in the cool
season turf world with average
temperatures in the 50s you know based
on the photosynthetic apparatus only one
measure of what will drive turf growth
but if you look at you know that measure
you know you're only a 25% full growth
only 1/4 of the potential to grow is
there so you're not growing very much
this is tricky because normally we
promote growth at this time to sort of
get play and maybe you did things in the
fall that are promoting growth to deal
with your early spring traffic but but
just in general you're not growing very
much now of course you go to where Mike
is you know and he's looking at warm
season turf if he's got average
temperature of 50 degrees that warm
season turf he's staring at brown grass
he's not looking at green grass until
his average temperatures get it quite a
bit out there but again historically no
matter where sports turf managers are in
general they're gonna prime for that
spring sports season you're doing things
in the fall you're setting it up good in
the fall so that comes out of the gate
ready to go and now it's like whoa you
got two feet on the break because you
got limited staff and you don't know
what kind of resources you got and can I
even get out there and mow and so these
factors become very important when
you're considering this right so let's
just look at the you know the stupid
stuff that happens every spring we got
really wet soils throughout much of the
northeastern United States a lot of guys
are going out there with their first cut
because they got cabin fever and you
know causing some damage you know
raising the height of cut is a good
thing and it should allow you to wait
longer to be able to do that first mow
at least in areas where you're just
starting to get growth now if you got
wet soils don't take a wide area mower
out there and turn tight in the wet
spots you know just the simple stuff
that we've got to watch out for that's
more likely to happen with a little
limited limited crew when we're rushing
through of course we're not seeing this
this would be a normal picture of
lacrosse but if you've got a situation
like this even though you've got limited
staff if no one's using the buildings in
those
are locked up tight and you've got a few
people you could come out and work
safely in the field part of our
discussion with Mike today is what are
the kinds of things that we recommend
doing so Mike you know you did a good
job I'll bring you in here on this I'll
keep the slides up for a minute you did
a wonderful job in writing this up with
Tyler your field manager here what to do
during cancellation and again a lot of
this presumes we can work safely I've
got a couple of other questions I want
to get you to just so you know the
breadth of what I want to talk about
you also mentioned turf grass
enhancement I want to talk a little bit
about phrase mowing as we get going and
then also this wonderful article that
you tweeted out from this high school
turf manager and-and-and coach a field
manager and teacher about some of these
things but let's start with let's start
with your article here and what it's
been like in Virginia first as the
lockdowns progressed and being further
along in the growing season
Phyllis it we've had situations similar
to what you've described I've got some
folks that have full staff and they've
taken advantage of this downtime to do a
great deal of renovation and that's
where this question came up from a coach
was would it make sense and we thought
it made perfect sense to get active on
those baseball and softball fields to do
something that otherwise during the
season they couldn't dream about so
essentially they were jumping one season
ahead instead of doing all their fall
maintenance that they typically try to
do they're like why not now and because
they're anticipating that baseball and
softball and everything opens back up
and Carl and I were just talking about
this before you got on Frank we all know
it's gonna go crazy because people are
so anxious to get back on these fields
so that approach or that question came
from a concerned parent that was
organizing people of the other concerned
parents from his girls softball team
here at Blacksburg high school to I
would like to know the basic steps were
limited in field maintenance first note
the high school parents do most of the
work what could we do and I'm blessed to
have a young man like Tyler who's one of
our
students but is also actually our
baseball and softball field manager and
I say to jurors I'm gonna clean it up
but I'd like this is your deal so he put
it together and he did a great job on
that article he really did and again
we're presuming that all the Kovach
safety standards are in place you know
one of the things that we walk a fine
line I think as extension specialist
Mike is we're having these conversations
but I'm not promoting you should run out
and do this if there's concern that you
know there's a positive in the community
or there's a positive at your school
district or there's a positive test on
your workforce and we're not really sure
you have to handle all these things
we're not saying oh I should do this
just go Leo Rossi old malice III just
want to make sure we're taught if you
have the ability to work safely because
I think as we begin to see the pain and
pressure the pressure to open is getting
greater of course right so we're trying
to find ways how can we return doing
things safely so what I'm assuming you
know management enhancements skin care
are things that we know we can
inherently do safely and then even in
your case you're saying you wrote this
for people who sort of dopes don't do
this for a living but are volunteering
to do it which i think is even better
because cuz then that's a nice thing to
be able to communicate it it brings both
of things together because in that
communication article let me show you
the quote it's so great that you brought
this up because this is a really
important thing let me show you what the
quote that this young man in this
article who you may know set out he says
that we speak different languages I
speak agronomy they speak athletics
right and and and and I personally he
says I personally speak various dialects
of football soccer baseball and softball
right so not only did you tell them hey
you know here's how you fix this but you
also wrote it in planing because Jim boy
there's a lot to be said for that
so that bed young man is Mark Moran he
is a the teacher the FFA
or the horticulture instructor at lehigh
school outside of Richmond he also is a
coach and so he he balances all those
worlds together and he's realized that
he is a great resource because he lives
both sides of the fence here and one of
his most successful things he does from
my perspective as a turf grass managers
sports turf manager is he's the best
communicator that I have in the state
for these other coaches because he can
speak their lingo as well so what do you
think let me bring you back here what do
you think about phrase mowing huge fan
of phrase mowing we've actually had
people that have gone through and have
been doing early season phrase mowing
especially south of here there there are
some concerns with it I when I first saw
this machine I'd assumed it had been
developed for Bermuda grass management
then learned more about it no it wasn't
but I'm like what a what a tool to put
to use on Bermuda grass fields because
frankly remember my old mentor dr. AJ
Powell
AJ always talked about the importance of
having juvenile turf and when this thing
came on the the market there that was my
first thought was what a way to restore
juvenility that they come through with
what's essentially a heavy-duty vertical
mower that picks all this material up
with all this possibility of adjustment
for what you can do and it scares people
to death when you first see it done I've
done a lot of hand-holding with
administrations about the sports field
manager just destroyed my field and I'm
like oh no no no give them four to five
maybe six weeks at the longest and
you're not going to believe the quality
that's going to come by the only concern
right now what that I would have in my
area of Virginia is we are still not
past our last anticipated frost dates
people are getting very anxious I don't
think they could kill it but I typically
see more spring kill of Bermuda grass
turf than I do winter kill that's my
concern for now for at least my area
here in Virginia okay so let me let me
take you out on this a little bit
because you know if we stay to the point
where the you know for us in the New
York epicenter area
could take a much longer time in urban
areas of month it could take a much
longer time what's the possibility of
doing something like this as a way of
reducing the need to mow on a regular
basis number one number two why not get
a little injury to Bermuda grass if I
can't mow it for a while is it kill I'm
worried and again people freaked out but
we've seen even in cool season grass a
rejuvenation of the stand as you
described Ajay used to talk about a
rejuvenation of the stand even cool
season turf that might be worthwhile if
you're still gonna get this period of
time until they're gonna get on there I
don't know what they're talking about
but I don't see us really out and about
until June and we're about to come into
a you know big steep like I need
everybody and five other people just a
month so what do you think about phrase
mowing as a way to really slam the
brakes on they are not gonna I did this
it's good I guess the only challenge
that I would see with it is again it's
could be Mother Nature trying to guess
what is going to happen in the world of
Bermuda grass where I've been watching
this being done and we've done some in
Virginia Richmond to the beach and our
warmer climates I've seen it done and
there's a lot of it's going on down in
the Carolinas and they're well they're
well on their way in the cool season
world you're right at that one thing
about this these fields aren't going to
be mowed any time soon and again this
idea this rejuvenation does apply to
both warm season and cool season it's
amazing how grass responds when you take
some of the its internal competition out
of the equation and bring it back mother
nature would still be the big one if I
had no dates or targets that I'm going
to try to open up and was getting really
aggressive in a cool season field I
would be nervous it'd be easy to me to
say it as an extension specialist you
should give it a try I'm always telling
people but that's me speaking I'm not in
your world
can you guarantee and in a bermudagrass
world I feel very comfortable telling
people go ahead do it
here's your risk I think the risk out
outweighs the rewards outweigh the risks
and
I think give me till mid-june I think
you'd be good to go the cool seas in the
world right now that's what we're
dealing with in Virginia and my coolest
climate says we we were warned we went
crazy
I've actually been probably the most
overpaid grass cutter in the state of
Virginia because we lost all of our
student labor out the turf Center so
I've been mowing cool-season like crazy
we're we're looking heavily at PG our
application so we're trying to shut
things down now with growth regulation
which I saw in Pam's article from Ohio
State so so back to this phrase mowing
thing I'm not you know I guess what if I
gave you the target let me just think it
through for a second cuz we got we got a
little bit of time for questions if I
know my target is the fall let's say
okay listen we're not playing baseball
this year and we're not going to
practice until the students are coming
back and the students don't come back to
the fall or we got a softball leagues
that aren't going to start until we
think it's not going to be safe really
until mid-july so let's say I gave you
in cool season grasses in your cool
climates July to August when there would
be sort of no use of the fields again
and I'm just thinking hypothetically
that sounds like a reasonable deal we
may open up but those kinds of field
juices might not be allowed for a little
bit longer is my sense and sounds like
you're not you agree so if they gave you
that target and again you're right I'm
not promoting radical hey let's shave
these fields but if you had a weedy
field if you had a lot of problems with
surface great you have things that you
can fix with some of these remedial
things that are really progressive even
trying them might it's if you got a
crappy field
the way I look at how you look at what
do you got to lose we're gonna get worse
I agree I agree I agree and so you know
I think you got to look at a couple of
other things if you did it and the
beauty of phrase mowing is how much
versatility there is with that unit and
what you can do because I watch people
now again I've said it's a tailor-made
tool for Bermuda grass it just struck me
is there's I've seen nothing
better for bermudagrass rejuvenation but
of course for any creeping grass you get
into the bluegrass world that you can
adjust this and still leave a good
number of those rhizomes in place most
people that I know of that have been
using this in the cool season world our
supplemental seeding I think that makes
sense and so again it's always this
constant battle in turf about
everybody's like so you tell me to tear
turf up to make it dense again and I'm
like yes absolutely that's what we're
trying to do I think all those things
come into play and I agree with you what
a way to restore field grades you know
to remove weed seed and again if you
tell me that window is is closed until
that point of time then that risk is
very minimal in terms of what you could
do and this could be the greatest thing
you can do your field in preparation for
that busy fall season and as you
mentioned this tool was developed by
define it by the Dutch guy for the rye
grass in weedy areas and reshaping these
football pitches and so the way I look
at it is we shave it leave it alone and
when you're ready throw ryegrass seed
into weeks you're gonna have something
with a little bit of work that or you
know a month out if you know when it's
going to be if you've got a bluegrass
space you're you probably could see
bluegrass that's in him a better idea
but if you've got it just a crappy field
that it was half weeds anyway it's a
perfect time to give you that
flexibility now we haven't seen phrase
mowing with these two things we've
noticed in cool season turf one is it
really it will take out subtle
washboarding so I think you should do it
and then consider rolling and I think
the Bermuda grass guys are researching
does that make the feel less safe right
so you have those issues but the other
thing we've noticed Mike and you said it
- we're pulling off some last year's
seed rain in some cases and almost
invariably in the three or four sites
we've done this at clover never returns
clover never one weed in particular not
dandelion depends I think the taproot is
and how deep you get but we have not
seen widespread return of clover so
there are these sort of goofy things
that happen and I do think feeding is a
component to it if I know my targets not
so default yeah and again when I think
about what you all are facing in the
Northeast in particular but other spots
this country that right now in Virginia
we're not there in terms of we still had
pre flexible pesticide use strategies if
you are in a situation where you can't
and again that you know when you look at
where this thing came from in terms of
basically seed harvest that was one of
its primary benefits and so it's another
one of these cases there are risks but I
think the rewards if done and and
justified and you really sit down and
think about what is the purpose of doing
this you could very successfully argue
that there is a place that this would
fit okay so Carl do we get any phrase
moment questions because I want to talk
to Mike about this great article from
his pal in Richmond and the way he's
approaching it sorry and and how you
know that back to me is a big part of
what you should be doing in our climates
where it really does not like a grass
growing yet you should be planning you
should be strategizing you know you
we're not having to deploy people many
people are on limited staffs if you're
if you're managing these fields or if
you're working with people like like
Troy is working with people that could
manage fields how do you communicate
that to those people so Carl do we have
any phrase more questions before we move
on yeah we got a really good question
from Ben and polymer he said so he's
talking about exposing the seed bank
with phrase mowing promoting crabgrass
growth
now we've obviously got you know had a
grad student Chris sicko who did some
research say oh that's right yeah the
best way to get crabgrass to germinate
Ben is the phrase moment April brother
I've never seen a better strategy to get
the more uniform stand of crabgrass I've
ever seen with that said that exposes a
vulnerable seed bank you I owe people
looked at that when we first did it
they're like oh my god this is a
disaster I'm like no no no this is good
because now I got the seed bank done for
the year what am I gonna get another 10%
crabgrass you should have seen this
blanket like it was a blanket of
crabgrass so I I think Ben's point is
well-taken there are going to be weed
challenges
like annual grasses that done at this
time could and likely will enhance their
germination I see that again as an
opportunity because even if you're
restricted even under the most
restricted cases even in New York State
you could argue an emergency exemption
when the crabgrass is young and spray
Fiesta now it ain't gonna be cheap but
it's organic right you can get an
emergency exemption even in New York
State when the plants are small Matt
Elmore showing that they work so that's
it this is a creek listen freeze well
Mike it's a crazy idea it drives people
crazy to see it right but right as we
research it it seems you know we don't
know what we're talking about I talked
to my guy is all the time we're creating
the language we're creating a whole new
language and I think ultimately in ten
years this is going to be a standard
practice on sports fields throughout the
world as soon as we figure out the right
way to do it but Ben's point is
well-taken if you if if you have a
history of crabgrass in your area like
we have where we've done this work
you're likely to bring on that seed bank
that could make things worse it might
mean the best thing to do is see the
heck out of it right after you do it and
rejuvenate the whole thing what do you
like that Mike you know it's weed
pressure let's get seed and again Ben's
point is spot-on
any time you disrupt the soil I mean
that's all you're doing is essentially
topdressing seed to go around a related
thing Frank we've had done some more you
say crazy stuff we've been doing dormant
springing of Bermuda grass in Blacksburg
putting sprigs in the ground January
February March and April young man
hopefully we'll get this published this
year he just finished his degree as
crazy as that sounds the biggest concern
with it was germinating crabgrass it
comes up so we had to have we were using
Ron Starr for the weed control as a
pre-emerge but it was amazing just
cutting it's freezing the ground in
january/february set us up for massive
crabgrass populations later to do that
but it worked like a charm and the only
time it failed was April which was when
we were in those transition periods of
whim we think we got dead sprigs from
the sod farm to do that so
again most of the stuff there's a lot of
people say is crazy you don't know do
you try Karl any more questions we do
have one on seating but if you want to
move to the communication article take
some more questions and then I think if
we refer people to the article you know
I know Mike and I spent a lot of time
working with sports turf managers to
help them do this communication I think
this article is the best one I've seen
in a while because I think one of the
problems that they have is that we do
speak different languages I think
sometimes people think sports turf
managers don't want anybody to use their
fields and that's a bad perception to
get the perception should be I want you
to use the field as much as you can but
we have to work together to make it work
and and Rick Moran talks about training
coaches to practice around a field in a
particular way so let's do the ceiling
thing and then we'll get back to the
communication okay so a couple good
seating questions Greg Travis so he's
saying that so we're obviously promoting
kind of higher turf heights to reduce
your mowing frequency but we've also
talked about seeding and some of those
traffic warrant areas he's worried about
the longer turf height potentially
shading that that seeded area if you are
trying to seed and do kind of a thin
stand but that's still growing
especially with the Sun angles being
really shallow what do you think about
that the seeding and the turf height and
then maybe even start a fertilizer areas
where the grass is taller and you've got
bare spots
I would actually come back and try to
mow some of those targeted areas down a
little bit to expose that soil a little
bit more to get the seed into and also I
think in our neck of the woods and where
Greg is in the Hudson Valley
it'll help with soil temperatures get
the Sun into there get some heat going
what do you think Mike yeah I agree and
the other thing that I'm preaching to
folks think about if you're blessed and
the budgets not going to be hurting this
year great but many people are going to
really face major shortfalls and so this
would be a great opportunity to refocus
on where do I need to do this
if you've got decent turf over here why
would you be putting seed out there and
if you're on a budget you're not going
to be and you're just going to be
working on like that ears of that
lacrosse crease that you showed that you
know has now moved out to occupy several
hundred square feet there's where you're
focusing on you're not focusing on that
other stuff that's already got decent
perfect place yeah and that's what Rock
talked about last week right remember
Carl he said he said yeah your best
fields probably don't need a lot of care
right now it's the crappy fields that
you got we should be spending your time
I'm with and that's why you know I
thought this was a good opportunity if
you have if you can work safely and
there are those fields to tend to that
communicating with people about doing it
and and and reallocating resources to
improve those fields has got to be
something you're considering but I want
to go back Mike are you raising the high
dekat are you telling your guys the the
industry in Virginia to get those
heights are cut up now on Bermuda grass
it's a little bit different because it
gets squirrely if it gets too tall but
I'm thinking cool-season guys I'm
telling them you know if you're normally
a two you can go to three if you're
normally an inch and a half you can go
to two and a half we're seeing a little
bit of everything
again I've got folks that have really
been aggressive in starting PG our
programs and they've got the budget to
do that and that's way they're managing
their mowing under limited they got
limited staff but they've still got the
money to do that and others have just
gone too we're in don't let it get out
of hand mode you know don't let it get
crazy don't turn it into a hay field and
then expect to restore it back to game
two dishes within a week but most of
them have raised their heights up and
they're in that three three and a half
inch range and trying to stay on top of
it that way because quite honestly
that's all they've got the ability to do
right now with their labor force okay so
let me let me transition here for a
second I'm a coach or I'm a community
member involved in the fields I look
over the fence and I see the grass three
inches or because you got limited staff
if you're raised at the three following
the one-third rule doesn't that let it
go to almost four and a half I don't
think they've ever seen a feel like that
and it get call it that what Dad what
the hell are you doing
how the hell that Mike well you got that
communication articles where it's going
to come in because you better be able to
explain just what the heck is going on
Frank that field that Tyler and I wrote
the article for which you mentioned
about social distancing that group got
their hand slapped because they took out
and started doing all these activities
and then were approached by the
administration to you can't all be out
there at the same time we admire what
you want to do they had to refocus and
so again the social distancing component
is you've said over over again it's
going to come into play here so you're
gonna have to practice and hone those
communication skills to get people to
understand this is the way it's gonna be
we're gonna get it back in shape and
right now this is our situation and and
I think furthermore you raise an
interesting point and I've heard it from
some buzzes around there is his people
are calling out their fellow citizens if
all of a sudden they see a baseball game
going on your the grounds manager you
see a bunch of guys playing ball out
there or do you have a number you can
call her are you responsible for going
out and breaking it up please that's why
signage right don't you love what Pam
did you then put the Freak put the sign
up right listen it doesn't alleviate all
responsibility it certainly might
increase the communication needs right
but if you're going to be involved in
policing now's the time to be setting up
that communication hotline so that if
you see people out there that shouldn't
be out there or if somebody's getting a
call about hey why is the maintenance
crew phrase mowing you better make sure
you're talking to people who are in
charge so they can communicate this yeah
and the one thing you mentioned what sta
is doing now and they've opened up a lot
of their education but you'll see that
the letter from President Jimmy Simpson
came out that essentially is sports
field manager to handle their boss and
say listen this is why I am essential
and I'm like what a great tool to have
it doesn't mean that they're going to
accept it but all we're trying to do is
establish some dialogue yeah and here's
a way to open that door yeah and I think
it's funny because I think what I've
realized is that's a you know
essentiality
is really fundamentally what has to
change because I think what we've
thought about in golf is no one believes
in this world that the game of golf is
essential to human existence can we just
get over ourselves about this thank you
very much thankfully no golf guys will
watch this anyway I think the question
has to be what kinds of activities can
we do safely you've got a mask on you
got gloves on here's the way we live now
for the next few years until there's
some safety about health I think we
better embrace these things as soon as
we possibly can if we expect to return
to any sort of normalcy but but I do
think these things are things we can do
safely if you think you can do them
safely otherwise you know one person
ruins it for everybody he got beaches
closed up and down the East Coast yeah
that's no one's happy about that of
Virginia can't go on a beach the cops
are pulling people off the beach the
cops got better things to do and pull
people off the beach at some point we've
got to think about what is safe ways to
return and you guys have a chance to
lead this discussion about what matters
and you can do safely out there I agree
and I think mostly across the country
that's what you see there exuberance was
their challenge in this situation if a
whole group showed up at one time all
out there working most of our sports
fields could be managed by somebody's on
the skin somebody's cutting grass they
can maintain appropriate distances not
raising your eyebrows but it is
something that you know we don't think
about that to pass now we do have to
think about Carl how we doing on
questions I think we've at the witching
hour yeah maybe just one more quick one
Josh Fontaine our technician here at
Cornell he's asking about after you
phrase Moe how to seed so hydroseeding
sliced eating any considerations you
would have there for the method of
seating you first Mike well I've seen it
done every way just simply from over
seating right over the top of that
surface because you certainly got sold
to seek contact in play for a standard
phrase mowing but anything that would
give you soil to seek contact last year
when I saw one the thing I hadn't seemed
um it made perfect sense was top
dressing and I'm like yeah and another
it's
another layer of time to it but again
what a great strategy yeah and I'm a big
fan because of what we've shown we've
also shown the same thing when you
phrase mo we've done some sod cutting
and phrase mowing and left it open for
almost the whole growing season my kind
of cutting surface and ice nothing grew
nothing grew we drove the slit cedar as
you talked about springing in
january/february we just drove it
through no seat just drove it through
and crabgrass came in Oh annual
bluegrass everything came up right in
the slits so I said well we got a Hydra
seat and so now I'm becoming a bigger a
bigger fan of proper Hydra seating but I
gotta tell you my turf extension brother
there's no research on Hydra seating as
and fine turf guys do it but there
really isn't I've read some papers in
Greece about guys that are doing it on
roadsides and certainly does some
roadside information but nothing in fine
turf I think that's a wide-open
opportunity as phrase mowing becomes a
more important component of what we're
doing what do you think well I think
that's a great idea and that's one that
I hadn't pondered that would have
application but I see where you're going
with that and there are a few more lawn
care companies around town again fine
turf it's not golf turf but that's their
standard means of establishment and oh
my oh my highway right away research
over the years that's almost been
exclusively from the way you could get
seed on some of these slopes in the
mountains right I call how we doing good
I think we agree any questions we're you
know just a little bit over half an hour
thanks a lot Mike it's so great to see
you I hope I see you in person soon when
I bring my hope back my pleasure my
pleasure this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu